the Pentagon worked with various
contractors and social media companies
to do exactly what we've alleged that
Russia and Iran and China do to the US
which is create fake identities on
social media to manipulate the domestic
political debate of those countries or
in America what those countries do to
America we do back to them sure and that
and that piece has never really been
fully explored and reported and here I
am in Twitter headquarters where I'm
wondering okay if if the Pentagon is
working with Twitter and Facebook to
create fake identities to manipulate uh
the debate around Iran and in areas
where the the Pentagon has kind of a
focus
hopefully there's something there and I
found more than I could have imagined